[Musique] il
n'y a qu'un seul Titanic que
je savais que je devais faire ce film mais
quel est mon crochet et puis ça m'est venu à l'
esprit
c'est une histoire d'amour
je suis entré dans le studio et j'ai dit
Roméo et Juliette sur ce bateau et le
reste est  l'histoire
prends-le pour voir M. Murdock
étirons ses jambes
[Applaudissements]
nous regardions toutes les jeunes
actrices qui montaient et venaient et le nom de Kate
revenait sans cesse non tu as vraiment besoin de la
rencontrer je pensais que d'accord je
la rencontrerais bien nous nous sommes mis  vraiment un
test d'écran à l'ancienne et quand je dis à l'
ancienne, nous avons trouvé un ensemble d'époque et
nous les avons mis en costume Rose
Rose à l'avocat et à partir de là, il
ne faisait aucun doute dans notre esprit que Kate
Winslet était la bonne personne pour jouer
Rose
nous avions notre Rose nous devions trouver notre Jack
Leo est entré et l'a juste fait sortir du
parc J'ai vu ça
une fois au Nickelodeon et j'ai toujours voulu le faire au
moment où j'ai dit qu'en fait il s'est transformé en
Jack et ma mâchoire a touché le sol  La mâchoire de Kate
a touché le sol et tout d'un coup, il y
avait notre Jack pour que chaque jour compte
bien, a déclaré Jack
pour le faire compter à l'étranger une fois que j'ai
commencé à travailler avec Leo, nous avons pu en
quelque sorte trouver notre propre rythme, il avait cette
énergie effervescente qui était  vraiment
magnétique je me souviens avoir pensé oh ça va
être amusant nous allons vraiment nous
entendre et nous avons vraiment
vu les gens ensemble et ils sentent
que l'amour ouvre à nouveau les yeux les gens
associent le Titanic à une grande
histoire d'amour je vole
antitica a résisté à l'épreuve du temps Jim
a écrit une histoire qui elle-même est intemporelle
les problèmes qu'elle traite de l'
histoire d'amour entre classes elle est toujours
d'actualité aujourd'hui j'ai 10 dollars en
poche je n'ai rien à vous offrir et je
sais que je  crois en une
expérience théâtrale je crois qu'il se
passe quelque chose dans un théâtre et
tu es assis dans cette pièce sombre le temps
s'en va je pense que tu es attiré
par ces personnages tu es attiré par
le Jeopardy et je pense que les gens se le doivent
de le voir sur grand
écran c'est d'autant plus vivant et plus
présent je t'ai je ne lâcherai pas
je ne lâcherai jamais
[Musique]